la mayor planta nuclear de europa
cercada por centenares de obreros y
ciudadanos desarmados en la primera
línea de los avances rusos
estoy agradecido e impresionado del
valor y el heroísmo de nuestros
residentes que salieron sin armas y
construyeron una cadena humana de más de
un kilómetro y no dejaron que ni el
enemigo ni su equipo entraran a la
ciudad
la planta de energía nuclear de esa
policía está ubicada en la ciudad
suroriental de enervar cerca de las
regiones de donges y lugares en poder de
rebeldes pro rusos y al norte de la
anexada crime a una de las principales
rutas de la invasión de rusia
sentimos que el estado no respalda e
infraestructuras como la estación de
energía nuclear de esa policía no serán
entregadas a fuerzas extranjeras
luego de que rusia tomara control de la
planta de chernóbil la semana pasada la
agencia internacional de energía atómica
se declaró preocupada por la situación
we are trying to make sure estamos
tratando de asegurarnos de que no
volveremos a tener sufrimiento añadido
por ninguna liberación de radiactividad
o cualquier cosa que tenga que ver con
instalaciones nucleares
with nuclear facilities ucrania ha
pedido asistencia de la agencia para
salvar sus plantas nucleares mientras
tanto moscú asegura que ha tomado
control del territorio alrededor de las
instalaciones de la policía que es la
sede de energía nuclear más grande de
ucrania con 6 de los 15 reactores del
país